اسمعوا جلال نجمه من نجمات الجيل الحالي
للمعين جدا في السنوات الاخيره مجموعه
اعمال ونجاحات حقيقيه ما حد يقدر ينكرها
عم نخلي بالك من زيزي للكبير للسوتس
بالعربي للغرفه 207 وقبل كل دول برضو
سنوات من الاعمال لكن هذا الرمضان نقدر
نقول انه وبدون مبالغه يعني انه شفنا
امامنا كلنا موهبه اسماء جلال بتتفجر في
الهرشه السابعه المسلسل اللي بتلعب فيه
دور سلمى عانت كطفله من اهلها وبتحاول
تتخلص من هذه الحمل اللي شالته بسببهم
واللي في نفس الوقت بتتزوج من شريف اللي
هو علي قاسم وبنشوف سوا العقبات اللي
بيخوضها زواجهم
[موسيقى]
الليله دي
الهرش السبعه من مسلسلات ال15 حلقه واللي
انتهى عرضه من ايام وماخذ اصداء واشادات
واسعه وخصوصا مع تطرقوا لمواضيع حساسه او
خط شخصيه اسماء في المسلسل صلاه الضوء علم
وضيع مهمه وحساسه كمان ومن اول ما بدا عرض
المسلسل حتى نهايته من ايام والارشادات
باسماء جلال ماليه منصات خصوصا كمان
الكلام عن النضج والتطور اللي الجمهور
لامسوا عمل بعد عمل
وهتنضم الينا النجمه اسماء جلال اهلا فيك
معنا يا اسماء منورتنا اليوم وكل عام
وانتم طبعا بالف خير وانت بخير يا رب
دايما اهلا اهلا بيكي اسماء يعني
صعب اوصف اللي انت عملتيه في رمضان هذا
لانه نحن اللي تابعنا المسلسل واللي الناس
اللي لازم يشوفوه بقول لهم لازم يتابعوا
المسلسل صراحه يعني انت اخدتينا مع مشاعر
مختلفه بين بين
الزعل بين الحزن بين مشاكل الاهل بين
الجرح يعني قديش فعلا هذا الدور كان صعب
حسيت
يعني خليني اقول لك قبل اي حاجه انا
مبسوطه ان انت تفرجتي ومبسوطه من فعلا ناس
قوي
الدور ده كان فعلا صعب بس
هو بسيط في نفس الوقت عشان اكون صريحه
يعني هو هو اهم حاجه ان هو كان يطلع زي ما
بيقولوا لحم ودم ان هو يبان انه دي بني
ادمه طبيعيه عاشت او تجربه
وبتطلع بتطلع منها في اوقات مفاجاه غصب
عنها في حاجات غصبا عنها فجاه بتفكرها
بحاجه مش لازم بقى نقعد كل حاجه نقولها في
خطوط او في كلام ممكن يبان في نظره ممكن
يبان في في حاجه وكريم الشناوي شاطر قوي
في ان هو يوضح ده
يعني كل حاجه بنت انت صح عندك مشاهد يعني
بتكوني فيها مع علي قاسم يعني فعليا مشاهد
من الحياه يعني مثلا هو بيقول شيء ما
بيعجبك نظره عينك او لفت وشك بتكفي يعني
كيف بتاخذي نفسك كذا بكفي هذا انه يدينا
الاحساس انه نفس كلنا عايشين دال مشهد مع
ازواجنا بالضبط
لما بس مش مشاهدي انا وعلي ق اسم برده حتى
بيتكلموا على مشاهد بين امينه وشاهين
وبيقولوا انه المشهد ده بالظبط واحنا
بنتخانق انا دي اكتر جمله بجد بتفرحني بحس
انه اوكي احنا عملنا حاجه حقيقيه او حاجه
وصلت للناس في المطبخ بتاعها
هي كانت حقيقيه صراحه زياده عن اللزوم
يعني الحقيقه لانه كلنا شعرنا فيها او مست
فينا شيء هل في هذه الشخصيه في اي ملامح
بتشبهك يعني زينا كلنا لقينا نفسنا في بعض
الشخصيات وفي بعض التصرفات او بعض المواقف
انت كاسماء
لا هي هي مش شبه هي هي هو عشان انا امثل
اي شخصيه لازم احاول اربط
خيط بيني وبينها عشان الخيط ده ممكن يبقى
مجرد ان انا تخيلت يعني ممكن ابقى اتقلت
بس قعدت فتره طويله قوي اتخيل هي مرت بايه
عشان انا مهما حاولت امثل الاحساس بتاعها
عمري ما هعرف امثله لازم احسه فانا لازم
اتخيل هي البنت دي مرت بايه بجد وهي صغيره
قد ايه اتسابت قد ايه حست كام مره انه ما
حدش عايزها ولا حد متمسك بها فكل الاحاديث
دي لازم ابقى حقيقي متخيلاها واربطها
بحاجات شبه الحاجات الموجوده بالفعل عشان
احس بالوجع لكن لا مش شبهي وفي اشياء يمكن
لعبته يعني على خط يعني خلينا نقول صعب
يعني مثلا طرحته وبكل جراه مثلا قصه
المساكنه هذا الشيء ما اقلقك
ما اقلقنيش لسبب بسيط جدا انه سواء انا
لما باجي اقدم دور انا مش بقول اسماء جلال
بتؤمن بايه او ضد ايه او مبادئها ايه او
افكارها ايه اسمها جلال بتقدم دور هي بين
قوسين ممثله هي لازم تتجرد من كل الحاجات
وتدخل تمثل جاهزه لان هي توصل صوره من
الواقع هو ده الغرض من الفم في الاول وفي
الاخر سواء في افلام زمان سواء في الافلام
دلوقتي في المسلسلات انا
بجسد حاجه بتحصل في الحقيقه بقول انه ده
نموذج موجود في الحياه لكن ده مالوش اي
علاقه باسماء جلال بتؤمن بايه او بالسبوره
بدعم ايه او ضد ايه فاهمه قصدي
بس مثلا انت في هالموضوع مثلا ايش رايك
رايي انا في المكنه مثلا
يعني انا حاسه ان هي بس حاجه حساسه قوي ان
انا اقول رايي فيها يعني حاسه انه
الموضوع ما يخصنيش يعني هي الموضوع بعيد
عني قوي بس كان ممثله اه امثل دور زي ده
لكن
رد رد ذكي ممتازه يا اسماء طيب كمان واحده
من الاشياء الثانيه
شعور الارتياح يعني الناس بين المسلسلات
اللي هي الجري وخطف وضرب ومش عارفه كله في
بصفه عامه في المسلسل نفس اللي عملتوه في
خلي بالك من زيزي برضو اللي هو نجح برضو
نجاح كبير في الناس عندها كان شعور
بالارتياح صح بيتفرجوا على مشاكل بس
مبسوطين ايش سر هذه المعادله تحسي
انا بحس ان ده بيرجع لكريم الشناوي ومريم
نعوم ودايما الناس اللي بيختاروهم ان
الناس دي مش بالمره يشتغلوا مع بعض الناس
تقريبا ثالث او رابع مره يعملوا مشروع
ودائما في في طاقه انت بتدخلي الاستوديو
مش بتدخلي ستوديو اللي هو التصوير العادي
الطبيعي انت تدخلي لبيتك التاني او بيتك
الاولاني لان احنا بنشوف بعض اكثر ونشوف
اهلنا وده فعلا
الاحساس اللي احنا حاسينه بقى لنا كذا يوم
انه احنا خلصنا المسلسل بس حاسين اللي هو
ايه ده احنا هنصحى من النوم مش مش هندخل
نسلم على شاهين وامينه وعلي وكريم ونصبح
على مريم ففي في حاله دفء كده معينه بتبقى
متواجده انا برجع يعني لو هشكر حد هشكر
كريم الشناوي فيها لان هو بيتمسك بالتيم
بتاعه مهما كانت الظروف وفكره بهم دائما
دي بتخلي احساس انه اوكي انت رجعتي لعيلتك
تصوري ايوه واحنا صراحه كان واصلنا هذا
الاحساس وكمان يعني برده اللي هو شيء برضه
مغاير انتوا بتعملوه اللي هي فكره انه مش
ضروري نعمل 30 حلقه مش ضروري نلزم الناس
بقصه 30 حلقه بتحسي هذا الشيء اريح ولا
كانكم بتخرجوا من السباق في نصه
[موسيقى]
شيك وحساب
بشيكوا حساب اسماء على انستقرام الصور مره
حلوه طيب وبشوف التعليقات طبعا في مديح
وفي نقد اكيد كمان وفي تعليقات اللي هي
برضو مزعجه قديش بتزعجك هذا النوع من
التعليقات اللي مثلا بتكون جميله
خالص اصل انا هقرا كم كومنت وبعدين انا
معظم الوقت انا ما بقاش اه انا بحاول
اتابع وابقى اللي هو مع الناس بتابع
ارائهم
وده بيبقى في التوقيت اللي عندي فيها حاجه
بتتعرض لكن انا مش شخص فاضي لهذه الدرجه
ان انا اقعد اقرا تعليق تعليق من الناس
وبصراحه بصراحه انا عملت كده هتجنن لانه
افرض انا
صدقت الكلام اللي هم كاتبينه يعني في
الاول بصراحه كنت اللي هو ببقى مركزه قوي
في كل كومنت بيتكتب واللي هو ايه ده الناس
دي متضايقه مني ليه طب انا عملت ايه قلت
طب مازانيا ممكن الشخص ده اللي بيكرهني
بكره الصبح لو شافني الحته هيجي يتصور
معايا عادي فانا عمري ما هعرف حقيقه
المشاعر فبالتالي نتجاهلها ونشوف وقت
التصوير ده الناس دي هتتفاعل ازاي وده
اللي هيبقى الحقيقي طيب انا بس قبل ما
نختم معاكي اسماء اول شيء حابه اعلق انه
يعني اقول الكلام اللي قلت لك اياه تحت
الهوا انه انت ما شاء الله جميله جدا وانا
لما اول ما تكلمنا قبل الهواء انا واسماء
سالتها بكل صراحه قلت لها اسماء انت ايش
حاطه على وجهك تفضلي يا اسماء قولي
للجمهوريش حاطه على وشك
انا حاطه انا ممكن اطلع لكم الحاجات
اعلان للبرانز بس اذا بتحبي لا خلاص طب
انا حاطه يعني احطها كونسيلر ايوه
حاطه بلاشر وحاطه ماسكره وبس والحلو حلو
يا اسماء ما يحتاج
شكرا لك ومنورتنا انا بس يعني ايه حبيت
انه اوضح انه ما شاء الله عليك قديش طالعه
حلوه وعلى طبيعتك يعني اسماء تجنن تجنن
تجنني في هذا العمل صراحه رائع رائع رائع
رائع يعني اعتقد من بعده خلاص انت يعني في
مرحله ثانيه تماما الان في حياتك صراحه
كلنا حبينا دورك صراحه وادائك فبشكرك جدا
وهنا فريق العمل كله حتى يعني في غرفه
التحكم كمان بيوجهوا لك تحياتهم لك
وبيقولوا لك المسلسل كمان رائع فشكرا لك
يا اسماء نورتينا اليوم كانت معنا النجمه
اسماء جلال
[موسيقى]